قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي الكسندر
نوفاك كان روسيا رفعت بشكل كبير حجم
صادراتها من النفط الى الهند كما ازدادت
الامدادات الى الصين عام 2022 اضاف نوفاجا
في كلمه القاها خلال اجتماع لقياده وزاره
الطاقه انا غالبيه موارد الطاقه في روسيا
اعيد توجيهها الى اسواق اخرى وصفها باسواق
الدوله الصديقه بل الدول الصديقه مشيرا
الى ان امدادات النفط الى صين ازدادت بنحو
22 ضعفا العام الماضي واشار نوفاك الى
اهميه الحفاظ على الزخم المتعلق
بالاستحداث اليات تتيح لروسيا توريد
الطاقه الى الاسواق الجديده
كتشكيل حلقات لوجستيه واسطول لنقله النفط
والانتقال الى التبادل التجاري بالعملات
الوطنيه
في غضون ذلك يبحثوا وزراء الطاقه
الاوروبيون المقترحات المقدمه من دول
الاتحاد لاعاده هيكله سوق الكهرباء بهدف
التغلب على الازمات المستقبليه الخاصه
بنقص الطاقه المحتمل بسبب حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا
وسيناقش الوزراء في اجتماعهم الشهري في
بروكسل امكانيه خفض الاعتماد على الغاز
الطبيعي وتمديد على الاتفاق بالمقترح الذي
طرح لاول مره في سبتمبر ايلول الماضي بخفض
توعي بنسبه 15% حتى مارس ادار من العام
المقبل كما ستتم مناقشه تطورات خطه التحول
نحو مزيدا من الاعتماد على مصادر الطاقه
المتجدده